ماسك يتمسك برسوم التوثيق في تويتر رغم
الاحتجاجات واستغاثه شيرين تخرجها من
المستشفى اخيرا والفنان احمد زاهر ضيف 25
سؤال اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
جدل العلامه الزرقاء للتر لازال مستمر
وامس كنا نتحدث عن ردود الفعل على قرار
ماسك بفرد رسوم على المشتركين اصحاب
الحسابات الموفقه اللي قيمتها ثمانيه
دولار شهريا وشفنا الجدل وردود الفعل
والشكوى واللي اغلبها رافض لفكره دفع
ثمانيه دولار شهريا للابقاء على توثيق
الحساب لكن ماسك ما زال مصر على رايه
وبيرد شخصيا على الشكاوى والاعتراضات عبر
حسابه في تويتر ساعه يرد بالكتابه ساعه
بصور او ايموجي المهم انه بيحاول يوصل
فكرته للجميع في الاول نشر صوره فيها شخص
مبتسم وهو بيشرب قهوه ستاربكس مقابل
ثمانيه يدور الارض وكاتب جنبها انه الزمن
اللي بيستغرقه شرب هذا الكوب هو 30 دقيقه
ونشر تحت وجهه او نشرت بتاعها وجه معصب
وغاضب لانه هيدفع تميدوا دولار مقابل
العلامه الزرقاء مع انه قيمه الاشتراك
ستستمر 30 يوم مو بس كده رجعنا شر صوره
الى الان شايفينها امامكم وفيها محادثه
بين شخصين الاول بيقول اتمنى دولار شهريا
مقابل حريه الكلام كثيره والثاني بيرد
عليه انه طيب تقدر تستمر في تويتر مجانا
بس من دون العلامه الزرقاء
يعني بكل طريقه بيرد على المنتقدين
وبيحاول يوريهم انه معه حق فقره انه مو
ناوي يتراجع عنه وفي نفس الوقت جالس بياكد
انه تويتر مو بسهوله يقدروا الناس يستغنوا
عنه وانه اكثر مكان مثير للاهتمام على
الانترنت والدليل قراءتهم الان لهذه
التغريده ولكن خلينا نرجع للمحتاجين
فواحده منهم هي عضو مجلس النواب في الحزب
يؤدي الديمقراطي الكسندرا اوكاسيز ونشرت
تغريده بتقول فيها ان جلسه بتضحك انه في
ملياردير وما سمته بيروش للناس انه حريه
التعبير تاتي مقابل اشتراك ب 800$
الملياردير عرف نفسه ورد عليها وقال لها
ماسك نقدر ملاحظاتك ولكن الان لا تدفع
الثمن يا دولارات زي كانه بيقول لها اوكي
طيب سمعناك بس ما راح يتغير شيء
ماسك كمان راح نكش لها صوره همم زي
سويتشرت بيتباع على موقعها الرسمي كجزء من
طرق دعمها الانتخابي ومكتوب عليها اسمها
وحتى دائره حول السعر اللي هو 58 دولار
وكانه بيقول لا يعني معترضى على ثمانيه
دولار في الشهر وانت جالسه بتبيعي سويت
شيرت عليه اسمك ب 58 دولار
على الرغم من كل ردود مسقطه توضيحه لاسباب
هذا القرار في دراسه جديده بتاكد ارتفاع
عمليات البحث عن كيفيه حذف تويتر بنسبه
500% في الاسبوع الماضي يعني من وقت ما
صار ماسك مالك ورئيس تويتر حتى عمليات
البحث عن مقاطعه تويتر كمان ازدادت 4,800%
[موسيقى]
في تطورات جديده في قصه الفنانه شيرين عبد
الوهاب اللي شغلت الناس وتصدرت وما زالت
متصدره العناوين وكان في كثير اشاعات طلعت
على الفنانه ان كان وفاتها او سفرها
الخارج للعلاج او حتى هروبها من المستشفى
يعني سلسله من الاخبار والاشاعات الي
نفاها محامي شيرين على صفحته الشخصيه في
الايام
الماضيه لكن في تزور جديد اليوم نسف كل
شيء اخبار من قبل كانت صغيره فمن بعد 17
يوم على دخول المستشفى خرج شيرين اخيرا
منها ونشر محاميها المستشار ياسر ان تش
على صفحه انه هي بصحه جيده وشكر كل من
دعمها وقال انه في فيديو قريبا هيشرح في
المستجددات
ولكن قبل ما تخرج شيرين من المستشفى كانت
تشير لها تسجيل صوتي وتم تداوله على
المنصات وهي بتطلب مساعده محاميها
مساء الخير يا استاذ ياسر ههه من فضلك
بتعمل اي حاجه عشان تخرجني من المستشفى
لان هم ادوني على ورقه انا مش عارفه ورق
ايه ده وانا عايزه اخرج من المستشفى انا
الحمد لله بقيت كويسه وكملت علاج يعني بقى
لي 20 يوم هنا فعايزه اخرج ضروري يا استاذ
ياسر من فضلك
طب يعني مثلا ما سمعته في التسجيل الفنانه
شيرين استغربت بمحامي هي ياسر قنتوش
وطلبات موسى عدداته واستغاثتها هذه طلعت
من بعد ما تداوي اخبار انه شيرين طلبت من
المستشفى البقاء للعلاج والمستشفى كانت
ابلغت النيابه العامه بقرار شيرين لكن
اللي تبين بعدين صادم وعكس ذلك تماما فنشر
محامي شيرين همم بيان قال في انه في تقرير
صادر عن المجلس القومي للصحه النفسيه اكد
انه شيرين صحتها جيده ومستقره وليست بحاجه
للعلاج الالزام داخل المستشفى وقال لي ان
المستشفى ارغم شيرين على التوقيع على
اوراق انه هي تبغى تفضل فيها للعلاج واكد
انه هو راح يتاخذ الاجراء هذا القانونيه
اللازمه بحقهم لانهم الان بيعتبروا
محتاجين شيرين وبدون وجه حق وهذا الشيء
مخالف للقانون ويبدا انه الاجراءات
المطولات وخرجت شيرين اليوم من المستشفى
[موسيقى]
ليالي الرياض مشرقه في نوفمبر نور الرياض
واحد برامج الرياض ارض من مشاريع الرياض
الاربعه الكبرى اللي اطلقها العاهل
السعودي الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز وهو
احتفال سنوي هام بيهدف لتحويل مدينه
الرياض الى معرض فني مفتوح بين الاصاله
والمعاصره وطبعا اقيمت النسخه الاولى من
احتفاليه نور الرياض في 18 ديسمبر 21
وحققت نجاح وتفاعل كبير جدا اليوم انه
يعود الى الرياض باطلاق النسخه الثانيه من
احتفاليه نور الرياض تحت شعار
جديده ورحت تستمر من ثلاثه لغايه 19
نوفمبر
[موسيقى]
طبعا احتفاليه نور الرياض مهتمه بدعم
الابداع ويحتضان المواهب الوطنيه
والعالميه في مجال الفنون وبتتميز هذا
العام في زياده عدد الفنانين المشاركين
فيها متنوع الاعمال الفنيه والابداعيه
وزياده كمان عدد الفعاليات المصاحبه وراح
تكون منتشره بشكل اكبر من حيث عدد المواقع
بنسبه اكثر من ثلاثه اضعاف عن النسخه
الاولى وكمان راح تنضم من 500 فعاليه
متنوعه و190 عام فنيه بمشاركه 100 من
الفنانين المعاصرين من 40 دوله حول العالم
بينهم 34% السعوديه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا احنا وصلنا لنهايه حلقتنا موعدنا
الان مع فقرتنا الاسبوعيه 25 سؤال ضيفنا
هذا الاسبوع النجم احمد زاهر اترككم مع
هذا اللقاء واعود والقاكم الاحد ان شاء
الله في امان الله
احمد زاهر 25 سؤال لازم تجاوب عليهم بسرعه
من غير تفكير دور توصفوا بانه دور عمرك
[موسيقى]
فتحي البرنس
ان ما فيش حاجه فارقه يعني
الدنيا ايه زوال الواحد في اخرته يعني مش
لازم نحارب ونعمل ونتخانق على ادوار وعلى
حاجات الدنيا زي يعني
وتعلمت كمان ان انا لازم اقرب من ربنا
سبحانه وتعالى اكتر انت ابو البنات الله
يخليك
ولد
[موسيقى]
وفي كل مره هدى كانت بتبقى حامل فيها كنت
باتمنى ان الحمل ده هيبقى ولد بس ربنا ما
قراتشي ورزقني باحلى اربع بنات في الدنيا
فانا الحمد لله مكتفيه ومش عايز حاجه في
الدنيا غيرهم ما شاء الله
[موسيقى]
يعني حاسسني بالمسؤوليه اكثر لان انا كنت
الراجل بتاع امي يعني حتى من وانا طفل
صغير فكان كان دايما عندي مسؤوليه ان هي
لوحدها فانا لازم اكون جنبها لازم اعمل
لها كل حاجه فاهمه لان ما فيش بابا موجود
معانا علشان هو اللي يتصرف يعني فده خلاني
مسؤول من وانا صغير
في حياتي همم
يمكن وفاه جدتي امي لان انا كنت متعلق بها
قوي يعني كانت هي كل حاجه في حياتي يعني
الله يرحمها ويحسن اليه
مع احد غيرك
دور رفضته ونجح جدا
يعني هم انا ربيتهم كويس عرفتهم كل حاجه
بشكل مضبوط عرفتهم ليهم واللي عليهم
عرفتهم دينهم عرفتهم كل حاجه في الدنيا
وهم اللي بقى ده رايهم وبعدين انا باقول
لهم ان انا ابوهم عندي خطوط حمراء انا
حاططها لنفسي عمري ما عملتها فهما ماشيين
على نفسها جميل ده
هو كل حاجه بالنسبه لي يعني هو هو استاذي
وابوي
والاكتشفني يعني هو جاء المعهد شاف طلبه
بيمثله في المعهد صغيرين في سنه اولى
قال انا عايز الولد ده فجاه لقيته مقابلني
كده حتى انا اتخضيت اول ما شفته يعني ايه
ده معقول انا مش مصدق نفسي انا واقف قدام
الاستاذ نور الشريف قال لي انت ممثل شاطر
قوي وانا عايزك معايا وتعدي سنه سنه انا
قلت خلاص نسيني يعني ما بيقابل ناس وبيقول
لهم انتم كويسين وخلاص يعني لقيته بعد سنه
بيبعثوا لي في مسلسل الرجل الاخر اللي هو
كانت بدايه انطلاق النجوميه احمد زاهر
بفضل نور الشريف وانا بصراحه اتعلمت منه
كل حاجه علمت منه تركيز في الفن تعلمت منه
تواضع اتعلمت منه الاجتهاد اتعلمت منه
الواحد لو مشهد واجتهد عليه ممكن يعلم به
مش لازم يبقى قد كده يعني صح
185 بعدين نحفظ جدا هل عملت عمليه التنحيف
انا
الزياده الوزن دي كانت بسبب الغده الدرقيه
انها توقفت ده مرض بيجي الواحد كل 10
مليون شخص ده اسمه ماكس ديما ده بيجي يوقف
الغده عن العمل يعني مش لازم تتشال او
يتعمل عمليه او حاجه زي كده لا هي وقفت عن
العمل فخلت وزن 185 كيلو وانا قعدت سنه
ونصف مش فاهم انا عندي ايه اصلا
وبعد كده عرفت
فلما بدات اخذ الالتروكسين او
الليفوثايروكسين اللي هو بيدي مكان افراز
الغده همم بدا الجسم يبقى في حرقه لان اول
ما كانش فيه حاجه ما كنتش عارف اخس فرجعت
بقى لعبتي بتاعه زمان بقى اللي هي
الاسكواش وهمم
بقيت العب كل يوم بقيت اجري بقيت اعمل
دايت قعدت سنه كامله في الموضوع ده لغايه
لما قدرت صح بالضبط
محمد سامي ده اخويا وحبيب قلبي وصديق عمري
محمد سامي في كينيا غريبه جدا جدا يا ساره
ما بيني وبينك يعني لدرجه انها بتوصل ان
احنا ممكن نبص لي بصه فاقول له اوكي اوكي
فهمت ما تجيش ما تقولش حتى الناس ممكن
يشوفوني يقولوا ايه المجانين دول ده ما
حدش في محدش فيهم يتكلم فهموا بعض ازاي
احنا واصلين للمرحله دي انا ومحمد لما
بنجتمع على دور اا بيطلع جامد جدا وبيعمل
بوبه وباخذ فيه جوائز يعني انا اكثر
جوائزى اللي انا اخذتها في حياتي
البلد بيتهمك بفرض بناتك على الوسط الفني
كيف بترد
اقسم بالله ابدا عمري ما فرضتهم يعني
بدايه من اول عمر وسلمى وكابتن هيما ده
كان اختيار تامر حسني لانهم متربيين يعني
على يدين تامر يعني شافهم وهم صغيرين قد
كده هو اللي قال ان عندهم موهبه حتى انا
قلت له يعني لا تامر ممثل شاطر وبتاع مش
عايز بناتي يطلعوا يفضحوني انا ما اعرفش
اذا كان هما موجودين ولا لا قال لي والله
اقسم بالله باقول لك موجوبين فا بعد اما
نجحوا مع تامر بقى كل الناس بيكلموني
عايزين ملك عايزين لايه طب انا المفروض
اقول لهم لا يعني
على فكره الواسطه ما بتنفعش افضل واسوا
صفه في زوجتك
افضل صفه همم
[موسيقى]
حنينه بمئه راجل يعني حنينه وبنيه راجل
كمان يعني هي اكثر واحده وقفت جنبي في
مرحله دي وضحت بكل شيء علشان تفضل جنبي
لدرجه ان انا في وقت من الاوقات كنت حاسس
ان انا خلاص باموت همم طلقتها علشان
تسيبني وتمشي علشان ما تتعذبش معي في
المرحله اللي جايه رفضت تمشي من البيت
وفضلت قاعده معي فانا دي دي ست ب 100 راجل
يعني همم دي افضل صفه اسوء صفه ممكن تكون
همم مش عارف والله هي جميله ما فيهاش صفقه
وحشه
همم احمد يا حبيبتي ممكن الكسل شويه طب
اوكي اوكي
ههه الله يخليكم لبعض ان شاء الله يارب
والله وفي اكثر من عمل مدامت عليه لان مش
شرط ان البني ادم يعني كل اختيارات وتبقى
صح رغم ان انا دايما مركز في اختياراتي
يعني ممكن اقعد بالسنه والسنتين والثلاثه
ما اشتغلتش اه في عوامل كثير بتجبر الواحد
ان هو ساعات ممكن ظروف ماديه ممكن حاجات
مش عيب يعني همم ممكن فيلم كلم ماما همم
يعني انا كنت ندمانه عليه ممكن في فيلم
اسمه كلب دليلي مع سامح حسين انا كنت
ندمانه على شكلي فيه لان انا اضطريتني
ظروف الماديه ان انا اشتغل هذا الفيلم
وانا كنت في وزن ما كنتش احب ان انا اصغر
هل محمد رمضان نمبر وان
الله اعلم يعني انا مش المفروض ان انا
اقيم زمايلي ما ينفعش ولا زمايلي المفروض
يقيموني ده دي حاجه للجمهور الجمهور بس هو
اللي يقول
الاهلي احد من اطفالهم لكن القلب وما يريد
مين اللي عندك انك تضعف تجاهها
الاربعه
اقسم لك بالله
احلى حاجه في حياتي طيب
الحمد لله طيب الظهور في برامج المقالب
بيضيف للفنان او بيقل لي منه
هو انا مش شايف انه لا بيضيف ولا بيقلد
يعني انا شايف الا لو في تهزيق وانا لا
اقبل بالتهزيء على الاطلاق خالص ان يعني
في برنامج معين مشهور جدا جدا بقى لهم خمس
سنين بيحاولوا يحصلوا علي وانا في كل مره
باكتشف اللعبه وبارفض ليه لان البرنامج ده
فيه تهزيق في الحوار على الكلام اه اه اه
ما ما لا اثناء الحلقه كلها في همم
تعليقات فيها تهزيق فانا انا ارفضها لكن
انا عملت مقالب مع ناس محترمه زي الاستاذ
هاني رمزي زي المدام فيفي عبده وما بقاش
عارف المقلب على فكره عشان بس الناس يقول
لك كل الممثلين عارفين لا انا عمري في
حياتي ما كنت عارف يعني لو اعرف مش هاروح
فهماني بس في واحد يقدم لك بشكل محترم وفي
واحد يهزق الواحد انا لا اكبر
في الاعمال تاخر
يمكن يمكن يكون اتاخر ولكن انا طول عمري
يا ساره طول عمري راضي باللي قسمه لي ربنا
لان لو ربنا مش رايد مش هيحصل ولو رايق
هيحصل فهماني فانا طول عمري باقول الحمد
لله وفضل ونعمه مهما نتاخر حتى اكيد دكتور
انا عندي 60 سنه مش فارق معايا الجمله
قلتها في احد ادورك واثرت فيك
مشهد
[موسيقى]
كان في مشهد عملته مش فاكر في مسلسل ايه
تقريبا في مسلسل علاقات خاصه كنت حكيت في
مشهد كده حاجه حصلت مع مع مع مع الاب يعني
همم
اثرت فيا لان انا انا اللي قائل الكلام ده
يعني انا اللي ضفته في المشهد لان ده موقف
حصل لي فانا اللي ضفته وانا بقوله كنت
متاثر قوي قوي قوي يعني مقصر في لغايه
دلوقتي
لا مش فاكرها بالضبط بصراحه بس يمكن
المشهد ده اكثر المشهد اثر في لانه حقيقي
لانه حصل انت فاهمه يعني حقيقيه مش مش
مجرد ان انا تعايشت مع شخصيه وعملتها بصدق
لا هو موقف حقيقي حصل عشان كده انا تعبت
منه قوي
ياكل اسرتك ثم تراجعات ليش
كبرت دماغي يعني عارفه ناس فاضيه يعني
قاعدين وراء البطانيه ما وراهمش لا شغل
ولا مشغله وقاعدين يشتموا في الناس خلاص
طيب اي شخص يخطب واحده من بناتك لازم يكون
مستعد لايش لمقابله الوحش
[موسيقى]
طيب كم مره حبيت
حبيت
في ثالثه اعدادي تقريبا كان طبعا يعني
المفروض ان هو مش حب يعني بس انا وقتها
كنت حاسس ان انا باحبك
ده كان حب جامد جدا جدا وبعدين همم الحب
الاقوى بقى كان امراتي الحمد لله
مليون مره وما امل اااه
كتير قوي ههه لا ده كثير قوي مش واحد بس
مش عارف ممكن اقول لك ايه ممكن اقول لك
مثلا زي سكور
سوكيت
فيلم ريتشارد برايمر ادوارد
الافلام القويه
شريره بس كان في حاجات في وسط العصبيه وده
انا كنت في وسط العصبيه
جدا جدا ومع ذلك
دي حاجات كثير جدا حطوها بصور ومش عارف
ايه على على الانترنت يعني وانا كنت بموت
يعني انا عندي مشهد رعبك وانت جالس مع
روجينا وهي بتخلص
[موسيقى]
برايمر
ربنا يخليك ميرسي يا ساره ربنا يخليك
حبيبتي
[موسيقى]